une page d'histoire se tourne le fameux
livret de caisse de Desjardins cessera
d'exister en novembre prochain ce livret
a été introduit il y a maintenant 120
ans peu de gens aujourd'hui l'utilisent
mais ça reste tout de même un symbole
important un symbole de départ avec nous
Guy Cormier le président chef de la
direction du mouvement des jardins
bonsoir Monsieur Cormiers
pour beaucoup de Québécois c'est un
outil emblématique ce livret il y a un
peu plus de 5% des membres qui
l'utilisaient toujours pourquoi ce
changement maintenant
le changement est simple notre
fournisseur nous a visé tout simplement
qu'à partir de novembre prochain il ne
serait plus en mesure de nous fournir
les livrets dans la mesure où c'est un
produit qui n'est plus très utilisé à
travers le monde donc on a regardé les
solutions il y en avait pas et l'autre
chose c'est que vous l'avez dit dans
votre introduction c'est 6 % de nos
membres sur les quatre points 5 millions
membres j'ai Desjardins il y en a 6 il y
en a 6 % qui utilisent le livret et de
ce 6% là il y en a 75
%, qui le mettent à jour moins d'une
fois par mois donc on voit vraiment
qu'il y avait une très faible
utilisation et là cinq à six mois à
l'avance on prend le temps de viser nos
membres pour faire une bonne transition
puis de bien les accompagner par rapport
à cette décision et ce livret là bien
sûr nécessite une impression au comptoir
au guichet est-ce que ça s'inscrit quand
même le retrait du livret
dans le recul ou je dirais le retrait de
certains services plus physiques de la
part de Desjardins au fil du temps non
il y a pas de lien nécessairement c'est
vraiment le fournisseur qui nous a visé
écoutez on avait un peu vécu la même
situation quand on avait mis à jour
notre parc des guichet automatique il a
été difficile de trouver des
fournisseurs à travers le monde qui
avait encore une imprimante à livrer
dans les guichets automatiques quand on
magazine autour du monde quand on leur
dit qu'on a encore délivré il y a
beaucoup de fournisseurs qui disent
écoutez ça existe plus technologies ça
existe plus service
qui font des il y a pas d'autres
fournisseurs du tout qui font des
livrets comme ça pour produire des
livrets là de cette façon là dans ce
format là et comme tel on a fait les
vérifications puis en même temps à un
moment donné on sait aussi dit bah là
écoutez le fournisseur est pas là il
reste moins de 6% sur 4.5 millions de
membres donc effectivement vous l'avez
dit les gens utilisent nos services de
façon différente comment on peut bien
accompagner ces membres-là on a pensé
que c'était plus porteur dans le temps
d'emmener ces changements là dès
maintenant façon très transparente en le
disant à l'avance plutôt que d'arriver
et de faire subir ça nos mains ça fait
longtemps qu'on parle de changement
d'évolution ensemble puis quand on
regarde par exemple vous avez parlé des
guichets automatiques les guichets
automatiques il y en a de moins en moins
il y en avait en
2005-2800 on est tombé à 2000 il y a
quelques années puis là on est à 1600
guichts automatiques en 2022 puis je
regarde le nombre de points de service
également le nombre de points de
services baisse aussi 1100 en 2015 724
en 2022 c'est une baisse de 35% jusqu'où
on va dans cette réduction de de guichet
et de points de service
on va aller aussi loin que les membres
consomment les services financiers avec
Desjardins à chaque année les guichets
automatiques sont utilisés 10 à 20% de
moins que l'année précédente et ça
continue et ça continue alors nos
membres nous disent gardez pas des
guichets automatiques qui coûtent
quelque chose prenons cet argent-là pour
l'investir dans des nouvelles
technologies que j'utilise plus sur mon
téléphone sur ma tablette alors malgré
tout il y a pas un autre institution qui
a 1600 automatiques au Québec puis près
de 700 points de service aucune autre au
Québec mais est-ce qu'on va les éliminer
au contenu
est-ce qu'on va les éliminer au complet
les guides automatiques éventuellement
là d'ici 5 ans par exemple moi je pense
très peu je pense pas que d'ici 5 ans il
y aura plus de automatique ça c'est un
peu comme quand j'entends il y aurait
plus d'argent papier ben on voit qu'on
atteint le fond un minimum où il y a
quand même des transactions qui vont
être encore papier moi j'étais directeur
général des années 90 qui était plus
supposé d'avoir des caissiers caissières
au tournant des années 2000 25 ans plus
tard il y en a encore alors je fais
assez grandes annonces là mais est-ce
que les guichets automatiques et les
points de service vont continuer de
diminuer en fonction d'utilisation que
les membres font de la coopérative et
des services financiers la réponse est
oui quand on regarde les l'économie en
ce moment qui ralentit quand on regarde
les résultats financiers des
institutions financières est-ce qu'il y
a des compressions qui sont en vue dans
le contexte actuel chez Desjardins
gestion qui il y a une gestion
rigoureuse comme on le fait toujours il
est clair vous avez vu les résultats de
nos compétiteurs cette semaine on voit
que avec le ralentissement économique
anticipé on va devoir probablement
mettre des provisions sur des prêts
additionnels les marges d'intermédiation
financière se compressent nous dans
notre cas au niveau de l'assurance
automobile il y a beaucoup plus de vol
d'assurance automobile et les coûts pour
réparer un véhicule automobile ont
explosé notamment avec les enjeux
d'approvisionnement à travers le monde
donc effectivement ces coups là qui vont
être générés dans les prochains
trimestres nous amène à continuer de
gérer rigoureusement donc oui il y a un
message de gérer rigoureusement autant
au niveau des effectifs qu'au niveau des
différentes dépenses j'ai Desjardins
tout simplement gérer rigoureusement de
la bonne gestion est-ce que ce sont des
compressions
pas nécessairement ça va dépendre des
activités peut-être que dans certains
endroits il va falloir justement
peut-être compresser certaines de nos
activités parce qu'on veut demeurer
compétitif c'est ce que nos membres
dedans à d'autres endroits on va plutôt
investir je regarde en technologie
actuellement on a doublé nos enveloppes
d'investissement donc on n'est pas en
compression au contraire on est en
investissement puis on est allé chercher
du talent donc c'est très variable dans
un grand groupe comme Desjardins des
jardins s'associent avec l'alliance de
l'énergie de l'Est pour financer les les
quatre projets de parc éolien retenus
dans le dernier appel dernier appel
d'offre Diderot Québec en quoi ce
partenariat là
est unique pour vous et investir
davantage d'aller dans l'éolien
pourraient-ils vous amener à investir et
à financer davantage moins c'est à dire
des produits fossiles
bah écoutez un produit là est innové on
est très content parce que on parle de
209 municipalités dans l'Est du Québec
les et de la Madeleine 16 MRC une
communauté autochtone des Premières
nations donc ces gens-là
individuellement pouvoir
à embarquer dans les appels d'offres
d'Hydro-Québec ou des partenaires
c'était un peu plus difficile là on a
mis en place une marge de crédit de 350
millions de dollars dès qu'il y a un
appel d'offres exemple d'Hydro-Québec
l'alliance peut immédiatement dire on
veut investir on aimerait que les
éoliennes soient ici on veut devenir
propriétaire et on va les opérer donc on
vient de donner une flexibilité une
proactivité beaucoup plus grande pour
ces municipalités là pour être capable
d'acquérir et de d'opérer un parc éolien
puis dans ce cas-ci les projets on parle
de 922 mégawatts pour ce qui est de
votre question sur les énergies fossiles
la réponse c'est oui on va on a depuis
2017 réduit graduellement à nos
investissements dans les énergies
vous êtes encore 350 millions en pré
brut au secteur mines pétrole et gaz au
31 décembre 2022
je le répète 0.6% des actifs sous
gestion vous comparez auprès des autres
institutions financières canadiennes
est-ce que vous allez à 0 %
ben regardez où on est en 2017 regardez
où on est aujourd'hui la direction est
très très claire la seule chose c'est
qu'on s'inscrit dans une posture de
transition pour justement graduellement
des investir des énergies fossiles et
remplacer ça par de l'énergie
renouvelable c'est ce qu'on fait sur une
période de temps qui va permettre aux
employants en question on a des contrats
avec ces entreprises là on assure ces
employés là donc on transitionne d'une
portion à l'autre je pense que
Desjardins là à ce niveau là exerce un
bon leadership au Canada ok merci
beaucoup c'est un plaisir de vous
accueillir monsieur Cormier bonne soirée
merci beaucoup monsieur filet en bonne
fin de soirée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI